so I guess it's time for me to speak
what is there for me to say after I'm
done you will sentenced me for my crime
so let me ask you now what is the crime
what is punishment it seems to bury from
time to time place to place was illegal
today suddenly illegal tomorrow because
some society says so and what was
illegal yesterday suddenly legal because
everybody is doing it and you can't put
anybody in jail I'm not saying this is
right or wrong I'm just saying that's
the way it is I've spent three and a
half years in your prison and i think i
paid for my error and if it's your
decision today to sentence me two more
years then I
my lawyer my lawyer that's a fun that's
a funny one he chose me be cool Billy be
good behave and I get your partner at
this at that well this has been going on
for three and a half years and I'm been
playing cool I've been good and now the
entire of being good because you people
lead me to believe that I had 53 days
you you hung 53 days and then you took
those 53 days away and you boo I wish
you will be standing where I'm standing
right now and feel what I'm feeling
because then you won't know something
that you don't know mr. prosecutor mercy
you will know that the quality of a
society is based on that mercy its sense
of justice its sense of fair play but I
guess that's like asking a bear to
in the toilet
for nation of pigs issue is funny you
don't eat him Jesus Christ forgave the
bastards but I can i hate i hate you i
hate your people and i hate your sons
and daughters because they big you're
big you're Oh pigs